je viens de la france hexagonale nos
concitoyens notre mère ont le sentiment
souvent justifiées d'être abandonné
oublié par paris donc aujourd'hui je
viens vous affirmer en tant que tout
comme vous citoyenne de france que je
suis indigné indignés par toutes les
inégalités économiques que vous subissez
indigné par 40% de chercher en plus sur
l'alimentaire que vous subissez un dîner
par le taux de chômage de plus de 30%
que vous suis indigné par le scandale du
chlordécone aux antilles et que je suis
indigné par les monopoles qui rafle tout
de l'économie ultramarine que vous
subissez aujourd'hui nos citoyens
d'apprécier diagonale nous sommes aux
côtés de nos concitoyens d'outre-mer
compatriote ensemble avec vous pour tous
ceux qui partagent nos convictions
agissez avec les reds rejoignez-nous et
adhérer